oh
love to cuddle everyone even he's
friends at daycare his teachers
very affectionate little boy he was he
was
it was perfect
on the 4th of august 2020 over 200
people were killed when an explosion
tore through beirut
i saw many civilians covered in blood
covered
in shards of glass clearly very
seriously injured there are some some
suggestions of fireworks other
suggestions of ammonium nitrate
fertilizer 7500 people were injured
and 300 000 were instantly made homeless
but there has been very little
accountability since the british
authorities they should know who is the
owner
of savaro the real owner because this
company is registered in uk
justice is the cornerstone for our
future
so
[Music]
the 4th of august 2020 in beirut
lebanon the country was in the midst of
an economic meltdown
hospitals were running out of medicine
and supplies
[Music]
and then this
[Music]
one and a half miles away from the site
of the explosion sarah copland was at
home
with her husband and her two-year-old
son isaac
you left your knee good we heard an
initial
loud bang and i i stood up and went to
the window to see
what it was but i couldn't see anything
at that stage
i walked back to isaac and the massive
explosion that everyone has seen on tv
happened and i was
i was thrown to the ground and um
isaac was hit with with glass
um
and initially i didn't realize how
injured he was and my husband and i we
grabbed him and we ran into the bathroom
because we weren't sure if there would
be another explosion so we thought that
might be the safest place
and when we got there we realized how
how injured he was and how
how much he was bleeding and we we just
we just ran we just ran out of the house
with nothing but
the clothes on our back um to try and
find help for him
isaac died a short time later in
hospital
the port had been busy as always there
were hundreds of workers there
and among them imad zaha al-din
here he is in the white shirt imad was
one of the first responders to a fire
which had broken out inside hanger 12 of
the port
this photo was taken moments before the
explosion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
2 750 tons of a substance called
ammonium nitrate
was being stored at the port and it
ignited after a large fire
so that is the official story an
accident but why was such a
highly flammable material there that is
still not
clear ammonium nitrate is commonly used
in agriculture as fertilizer
but it can also be used to make
explosives
documents suggest it was ordered from a
company in georgia
and was on its way to be delivered to
another company in mozambique
when it was held in beirut indefinitely
but one lebanese investigative
journalist has been digging a little
deeper
and uncovered murky and unexplained
connections
i tried to contact fem the mozambique
factory and also the georgian factory
both did not cooperate mainly in georgia
because they said that the owner changed
so they cannot give us any information
but the firm in mozambique did give him
a document
on which he spotted a uk company called
savaro
it had the same registered address as
companies owned by
two syrian businessmen we searched the
addresses of safaro
we found on two of these addresses two
companies with real owners
and the two of them were the syrian
businessman
who lived between syria and russia one
of them is george
haswani and the other is
both were sanctioned by us in
i guess 2014 or 2015. and actually ahmad
khuri also is the
brother of mudal al-fury who's another
syrian businessman and he also was
sanctioned in 2015 i guess by the
americans
and this was also alarming for trying he
was sanctioned for many reasons
including
trying to bring ammonium nitrate to
to syria at the end of 2013. that was
among the things he was accused
of since faras's report emerged the
syrian businessman
imad curry has denied any links to
safaro
as has george haswani
cyprus georgia russia syria
lebanon mozambique and the uk
isn't it weird that after six months a
journalist whether it's me or somebody
else will be the one
working on the story of savaro i have
talked to
the owner of the owners of rustavi azot
in georgia
i have talked to the owners of fem in
mozambique the factory i have tried to
talk to
the owners of savarro in cyprus did
anybody
try to reach you from the lebanese
authorities and they said no nobody
tried to reach us
they just wanted to put few people in
jails famous names
but not necessary the big shot
so people will say okay they put some
some people in the jail it's okay
and they will forget and actually that
did not work out
sky news asked lebanon's caretaker
justice minister for an interview
but she was unavailable lawyer melem
khalaf is representing the thousands of
families affected
he is calling on the british government
to stop the request
by uk registered company safaro to be
liquidated
the crime is complex it's not a simple
accident
it's something very complicated
from the uk it's a crucial
attitude from the mps we need to know
why the people of
these companies came and
asked about liquidation why
in this time after all this
investigation
all these effort
to help the people and to give them hope
they are not alone this is the real
message
they are not alone and we will keep move
till the judgment the final judgment
because we want justice
and those calls have not gone unheard a
letter from mp margaret hodge who chairs
the british
parliamentary group on anti-corruption
has written to the uk business secretary
urging immediate action
so what now guess could you may isaac
um
[Music]
how has this changed my life
it's destroyed our life um it's
i mean with isaac was everything to my
husband and i he was
he was the center of our universe
oh really for me as his mother it's like
it can be like a
physical pain missing him you know when
they talk about people who are missing a
limb they can still feel it and it
can hurt and that's what it's like is
like i feel him
i i feel his absence and it's painful um
physically painful
justice accountability closure they are
all different things to different people
but all the victims here those who are
gone and the many thousands which this
terrible explosion still affects
need answers and they need help well how
long
you know when
we need help we need help from britain
we need help from russia we need help
from georgia because again also
authorities in georgia should force the
owners of the factory
to show all the documents they have
related to to do
for this shipment uh syrian authorities
should help because
those businessmen are syrians they
should help and trying to at least
foreign
foreign
you